- We are here with the cast
of "Jurassic World Dominion".
Give it up.
(audience applauds)
So, DeWanda, did Chris
give you any advice?
You know, it's an action movie
and he's done lot action movies.
- [DeWanda] He had a lot of tips.
No, he had every tip.
I keep trying to get him to teach a class
on how to be an action hero.
- [Bryce] He's so good.
(Chris laughs)
- [DeWanda] Okay, I just kind of...
- [Kelly] Wait, and
it's kind of awkward...
- [DeWanda] He spreads the wealth.
Okay, yeah, oh, let's talk through this.
I'm glad this image is here,
now I can talk through this.
- Okay.
(women laugh)
- Okay, okay, all right, great.
So, Pratt was legit like,
he was like, "All right,
so the camera's this way,
your arm can't be back here.
It needs to be angled right here".
- Oh, it's like choreography.
- It is choreography, all right?
It's like, the level of specificity,
the knee bend, everything about it.
I just, I think you're the most brilliant
human being ever and...
- Aw.
(audience applauds)
- Just very generous.
- Oh, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Like, wildly.
- That sequence, that
sequence is really freaky.
We, we introduced this character,
this dinosaur called...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- A Pyroraptor.
- Yeah.
- [Chris] And, uh...
- [Kelly] I didn't know
what it was going to do.
- Right?
- I know.
- [Kelly] And then, I was like, "What?"
I was like...
(Kelly laughs)
Yeah.
- Yeah, a lot of...
- At first, you're like, "Aw".
(DeWanda laughs)
- A lot of people have said like,
there, you know, you read some,
maybe comments online and
people talk about like,
why has "Jurassic" never
had a feathered dinosaur?
Because you know, all
birds are descendants of,
of Raptors and dinosaurs.
So, you know, dinosaurs had feathers
and they didn't put feathers
and that's not real.
And so like, I think...
- They sound just like that.
- That's right.
(DeWanda laughs)
- He's not bitter at all about it.
- And if that's you, I'm sorry,
but I'm making fun of you.
(women laugh)
But, I think this is like, kind of like,
an Easter egg for folks,
who'd always wanted a feathered dinosaur.
So, there's this beautiful,
red feathered dinosaur.
It looks like Thanksgiving gone wrong.
It's called a Pyroraptor.
And the thing is freaking terrifying.
- It looks like a terrifying chicken.
- [Chris] Yes, that's right.
- Yeah, like a giant, like
mutated, terrifying chicken.
- [Chris] Yes, yeah.
- That also swims.
- That also swims, yeah.
- The part where I was
like, "I'm sorry, what?"
- Yeah.
- I was like...
- [DeWanda] Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, that sequence is
really, really awesome
and terrifying and...
- And then you think,
because there's this part
where at one point in the
film, it's like, they go back,
like someone goes back for
someone else and I'm like,
"What would you do in that
moment, in real life?"
- [DeWanda] In real life.
- If like, it's, let's say a grizzly bear.
(women laugh)
Like someone's back there and you're like,
"We probably aren't both gonna make it".
Like...
(Bryce laughs)
So, maybe it's your turn
to go, like I don't know.
- Thank you.
(Bryce laughs)
- It is like, thank you for this,
but I will live for both of us.
(Kelly chuckles)
It's like, because
there are these moments,
you see in action movies and you're like,
"What would we really do?", I don't know.
Because I've literally
been in like a shark tank,
where like, the back of
it looked like it was gone
and my brother and I proceeded to go...
(Kelly screams)
And we threw people in.
(Kelly and Bryce laugh)
Like, in the water all you hear is...
(Kelly hums)
And we're just like, my brother and I,
we know who we are deep down
and we're not going to be the ones.
(audience laughs)
Like, it's like, we are like, yeah.
- You're like, "I'm not the hero".
- I'm flight, you're
fight, go, it's like that.
So wait, so, did, did you
grow up loving dinosaurs?
Anybody? Y'all, were y'all like...
My kids are both, my girl
and boy love dinosaurs.
Were y'all nerds about that stuff?
- Did you, I was super into
the movie "Land Before Time"
as a kid.
- Oh my gosh, me too.
- We actually named our
family dog Little Foot.
(Chris chuckles)
- [Kelly] Yes.
- After, after the main character,
after the Brachiosaurus.
- I loved that one and "FernGully",
I was obsessed with that
one and "FernGully".
- "FernGully"?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was like, I feel like "FernGully"
single handedly made
me an environmentalist.
- Single handedly taught
me about the oldest tree
on planet earth, hi.
(DeWanda chuckles)
I'm just saying, anyway,
good songs as well.
But what about, what about you?
Mamoudou, like, were you a dinosaur fan?
Were you a nerd as a kid?
- The biggest nerd.
I've transferred my nerd
onto other things since,
but I was, I lived, I grew
up in DC, the DC area anyway.
Like, like you DeWanda, yeah.
- [DeWanda] Yeah, DMD area.
- That's right.
- Maryland.
- And the museum of
natural history is there
and I was just obsessed.
- [Kelly] That's great, yeah.
- Yeah, all my uncles would
always take me over there
and yeah, I just got to explore.
But I forgot all about that time period,
until I got cast in this.
And it was just kind
of, a wonderful surprise
to be like, "Oh wait,
I had this whole part
of my childhood locked away
until I got cast in this movie".
So, it's really cool.
- Yeah.
- I know, it's so fascinating.
And like as a nerd,
that's like, not in y'all,
I'm like in the music world.
- [Mamoudou] Okay.
- It's fascinating like,
whenever you see stuff,
like it's amazing.
People are so talented
at what they can do.
And y'all are talented too,
when you have to do it with like fake,
like, it's, you're talking to somebody,
like, it's just, I don't know.
It's so like, otherworldly
to me, it's a talent.
(audience applauds)
I have a question, so if
you could only pick one
of your cast members to like,
save you from a dinosaur
attack and apocalypse,
like just some, just the
world was going wrong,
who would you pick?
- God, I might have to,
you know, you know...
(audience laughs)
Let's see.
(Bryce laughs)
- Mamoudou, is like,
"Come on, come on, come
on, I'm here, I'm here".
- Well, I could pick Mamoudou,
because we could sit and we
could talk MMA the whole time.
You know, we could watch
old UFC fights together.
- Oh, yeah, you could pick that guy
to help you fight off other people.
- [Chris] Yeah, that's right.
- Yeah.
- He's got, yeah.
And Jeff, if I pick Jeff,
I'm going to be endlessly entertained.
He's going to, you
know, he's going to sing
and come up with great ideas.
If there's a piano there, especially
I wouldn't even want to leave.
And you know, I pick, I pick DeWanda.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- DeWanda's an action hero.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(DeWanda chuckles)
- Okay, so if you know,
what she learned on this film
would absolutely be utilized.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- To, uh, to save me.
- [Kelly] So wait, who would you take?
- [Bryce] The thing that I always say
and have always said
since like, I met Chris,
was that if, if an apocalypse happens,
like I'm heading to the Pratt household.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- He is ready, ready and so...
- [Kelly] Ready, ready?
- He is ready, ready
for anything to happen.
- Interesting.
- Yes.
- I'm like that, you
mean like, you're ready.
Like you have, I'm, like, I'm just saying,
people made fun of me
and then COVID happened
and I was like, "Who's
house you coming to now?"
- Yes, exactly, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He's, he's, he's ready, ready.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And so I would, I would go
to his household for protection.
But when you think about
like the experience
and what that lockdown might be like,
you know, if you're hiding from dinosaurs
or whatever this circumstance might be.
- [Kelly] Which happens.
- It's not just about
staying alive, right?
It is about also, still
trying to live your life
under those circumstances.
In which case, everyone
else comes into play.
(audience laugh)
- None of you would protect her.
- The vibe will be fine, but
it will be kind of a drag.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] He would help me.
- They hate survival skills,
you'd definitely pick them.
- Oh, yeah, you'd be making
me drink my own urine,
immediately, no question.
- Yeah, drink that.
Like, you have so much
water, drink the pee.
- You can do it at least
once, you can filter it.
- Yeah.
- It's a real thing.
Okay, what about you, DeWanda?
- Bryce, I would choose Bryce.
(Bryce gasps and chuckles)
I would choose Bryce,
I would choose Bryce.
Easily, because I would
feel the most emotionally
and psychologically safe in her presence.
Because after you get over
the like, initial, like,
"Oh my goodness, I'm
physically in danger".
Then you're just like, you know,
there's always that threat
that you could lose your mind.
So, I feel like I would be least likely,
to lose my mind with Bryce.
- Thanks, DeWanda.
- All, all of you are pshycos.
Like, all of you are crazy.
(Kelly chuckles)
- Cut, cut two.
All of us are in the room and you're like,
"I made the right choice".
- I think this one question
is going to ruin friendships, wait.
So wait, Jeff, who would you pick?
- Every one of these guys, they are...
- [Kelly] Peacey, peacey.
- Actually possessed of
unusual leadership qualities
in real life.
And we were in some difficult situations,
not facing real dinosaurs,
but each one of these
guys is a dream member
of the leader, leadership team.
Plus, Isabella Sermon, who's in the movie,
she is very powerful and very brilliant.
And you, when you see the movie,
you'll see, I'd also include her.
- [Kelly] Okay, I like it.
You've even added someone
else, that was so nice.
Politician, I liked it, I liked it.
What about you, Mamoudou?
- You know, I was going to say Chris,
but he didn't pick me, so...
(Kelly and Bryce laugh)
But I have to rethink things
since he's ready, ready.
Are you a hoarder or what's the deal?
- No, no, can I defend this?
I don't even know this
man, but I'm saying.
- Thank you, thank you.
- It's not hoarding, it's not
and it's not a doomsday prepper,
it's just being prepared.
- For every single situation.
- It's just being prepared.
Everyone's coming to my
house too, so whatever.
- Yeah, like he gave me a satellite phone
for our wrapped gift.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I
have a satellite phone.
- Yeah, that's like really thinking.
- [Kelly] That's a normal
thing if something happens.
- We should probably exchange
satellite phone numbers,
just in case...
(beeping)
Goes down.
(audience laughs)
- I'll be like,
"Listen, I'm checking in with
Kelly Clarkson right now".
(audience laughs)
How're we doing over there, Kelly?
- She is in the mountains of Montana,
that's where I will be.
(Kelly laughs)
So wait, who would you pick though?
- I'm going to go with Sam
Neill, he's got a farm.
(Bryce and DeWanda gasp)
He lives in New Zealand.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] He lives in New Zealand?
- And he's got two paddocks.
And you know, if it's
the end of the world,
I'm just drinking with Sam Neill.
- [DeWanda] Why did I follow the rules?
- [Bryce] He has a winery.
- Why did I follow the rules?
Both of you were like,
people who aren't here.
- [Kelly] Wait, he has a winery?
Well, what's that mean to you?
- [Bryce] Nothing.
(Bryce laughs)
- [Kelly] Okay, I was like, "Wait, what?"
- Yeah, right.
- Nothing, but for everybody else.
I mean, it's you, you, you are correct.
- [Mamoudou] I, yes.
(Mamoudou laughs)
- [Kelly] This is who I'm going to pick,
I feel like I'm prepared
enough, I don't need him.
But, I, I think I'm
picking the non-alcoholic,
so I can just have it all to myself.
(audience laughs)
Because if..
(beeping)
Is actually hitting the fan,
I'm going to need alcohol.
So, just, just slow it down.
You know, some of us are ADHD.